i got my two cents i ask you each week
yeah two two
sense my two non-fundraisers i ask you
each week on my instagram talks money to
give me your questions and i will
unrehearsed look at them and give you
what's
first thing that comes to mind so thank
you guys if you ask some questions out
there i see a bunch of questions uh as i
look at my instagram appreciate that you
actually don't look at them because i i
i'll be honest at first i was like
there's no come on he has to look
through him but i've seen you kind of
just been floored by some kind of like
someone came in while being doing the
show oh well good yeah i don't know hear
it okay so
um
here we go
here we go here we go here we go
um
number one this is from the blind sides
best jobs for college students wow best
jobs so here's how i would look at this
again first thing that comes to mind
best jobs for college students
short-term versus long-term short-term
whatever just makes you money so you can
get by in college right you just need to
make money cool whatever it is
long-term
whatever you see yourself doing in the
future whether that's an internship or
whether that's sort of being an
apprentice or whether that's working in
a field that you can see yourself
working in long term that's a difference
yeah so anyone can just get a job you
know i
i mow lawns i whatever i do with my free
time i i babysit i do food delivery i do
uber whatever anything they can make
money that's the easy part that's not
complicated the hard part is figuring
out what you want to do long term yeah
and then focusing on that and doubling
down on that even if you make less money
interning right yeah that's my advice on
that
um
al red kong says how can one become
wealthy in a third world country is
there a possibility
yes yeah what is it
what's the possibility yeah how can you
get wealthy in a third world country i
mean
people get wealthy in third world
countries i assume all the time i've
never lived in a third world country so
i don't necessarily even answer this i
think there's a misconception that you
have to live like in these states to be
rich and successful like uh i disagree i
think it all comes down to like
discipline and want in need yeah there
are more obstacles in third world
countries absolutely but a lot of people
in those countries are just
they're obviously the government kind of
makes you shove your head down be like
but you you can come you don't have to
come to the states to do that
like you can't 100 do it it all comes
down to discipline and how much you want
it and how
like just
using all your resources
um being useful being resourceful 100 i
mean you can
run a business you can
non-fungible tokens you know what i'm
saying like there's so many different
apps when there's a will there's a way
even if you're in a third world country
that's exactly it okay
david
dominating
and a roth are are roth 401 k a roth
401k or a pretax 401k and why
um bro i don't know what you're making i
don't know what you're doing but you're
on the right track the fact that you're
asking these questions and then you're
doing at least one if not two of them is
awesome anything with a roth in the word
is awesome okay i'm telling you right
now because you can never get taxed
again yeah that's the whole thing with
the roth whether it's a roth 401k or a
roth ira
you know how much taxes you're going to
owe when you retire david when you have
a roth acero
a big old goose egg that's a beautiful
thing because if you have a 401k which i
have no doubt i'm going to owe taxes on
that when retirement but with the word
roth just think no taxes
long term
401ks deferred tax you pay the taxes
later
and um roth ira is tax-free you pay the
taxes now never have to pay again ever
the tax man is coming we learned that
with nfts would you rather pay now or
would you rather pay later let me try to
get into my phone here
to get these other questions this is
here we go brought to you in part by
um
what percentage of my paycheck should i
automatically save at least ten percent
this is from at least ten
ideas
ideally twenty percent right if you can
get to 20 you're g yeah there were times
in my life where i was i mean this is
when i was no so you're saying no lower
than 10
if you can some people are living
paycheck to paycheck but the goal is
minimum 10 yeah if you get to 20 you're
a g yeah some people i know that are
just like look i want to retire early
they're saving 50 of their paycheck if
you can't yeah pick a number if it's one
percent right now start with that next
month get to two
all right next year get the five
whatever it is
increase it increase it over time okay i
love it
i love these kind of questions people
are thinking how can i retire what kind
of investment accounts how much should i
be saving this is what's up yeah
i guess less questions about instant
gratification more like hey how can i be
set for later yes that's good yes it's
not about buying things as being able to
do things yeah that's what's up
um
and macri says come to toronto
no
i'm not going
i'm not going it's an easy one no that's
an easy one all right next lucas morasso
says once you got 10k in saving which
percentage do you save in cash and which
percent do you invest i love that
question
the 10 rule okay you've got 10 10 10 10
again you've got 10 grand saved now
you're out of your paycheck take 10
percent out now you start investing that
now you're putting that to your 401k now
you're putting that your ira all right
if you're if you're if you've got more
than 10 put 20 percent it's all
percentage of what you're comfortable
with but where you start now doesn't
necessarily mean need to be where you're
at six months from now 12 months from
now i love where your mindset is at
again guys
half of money is knowledge all right
cool i know that i need a 401k i know
that i needed a roth ira i know that i
need to save 10 grand i got it i got it
the half of it is knowledge
the other half is behavioral are you
actually freaking doing it are you doing
the 10 are you doing it cool i know that
i need to say i have a retirement
account four years later i still haven't
opened up my retirement account what are
you doing
so half of it is understanding half of
it is knowledge the other half is
actually doing it the doing it is the
hardest part right okay
so
uh just
do it just do it um is valuetainment
hiring kelvin stock stockdow says yes we
are hiring we are growing if you love
valuetainment and you want to live in
south florida
send your resume yeah okay hit us up
um
here we go thoughts on etfs awesome
exchange traded funds wait wait wait oh
okay all right thoughts on et what
that's
like nfts etfs yes nfts etfs wtf what is
happening right now etfs are traded
funds tgif
um etfs are exchange traded funds
they're very similar to index funds the
difference is you can kind of buy and
sell them like their stocks um i'm a buy
and hold guy
um do you invest your money in something
other than stocks and real estate yeah i
talked about a little bit of crypto i
talked about um an nft platform um i i
you know i i haven't touched gold or
silver yet that's something that i need
to look into robert kiyosaki gave me a
lecture you get you get yourself some
silver boy yeah if i get my hand if i
get my hands on you you don't have no
silver that's the one thing if i ever
like
kiyosaki silver
um
julio casser says how to get better at
closing sales
how to get better at closing sales
number one to be good at sales you need
to ask questions all right i used to say
that selling is telling this is why you
need this is the best thing ever and
this you got to get you got to buy it
right now it's all about asking
questions asking questions
um but then when you actually are close
to a sale know the difference between
being
um
you know on the ball sharp following up
or just being unknowingly aggressive
dude i told you i'd think about it like
i've told you 10 [ __ ] times i'd think
about it let me get back to you in a
week i don't need you to call me every
single day right but if i said i need a
week and you follow up with me hey it's
been a week how are you doing you're on
my mind can we talk yeah okay cool just
stay present stay
there's a difference between being
like on the ball yeah and being on point
and being annoying and aggressive right
know the difference which one are you so
that's uh that's my that's right there
uh a couple last questions
and then we will wrap this thing up
hunter
timpson says what to do with 45 000
inheritance i've got a good idea for you
do nothing for six months there it is do
nothing for six months we talked about
this earlier talked about it i don't
know how much money you've got saved up
forty five thousand dollars can be a
life changer or it could go out the
window
very quick
go buy a car you're done so this 45 000
can change your life if you're smart and
if you invest it and you save it and you
do things with it that are long-term or
you can go have a great time and be done
with it in a year yeah choice is yours
but i would wait six months before i do
anything with that 45 000 inheritance
and respect to you for even asking that
question hopefully you're listening to
this advice
um
last couple questions let's do this
danny lama says in times of uncertainty
what do you recommend for stock market
investors
not to panic and cash out i'll give you
a personal story and it's happened to me
twice and i would highly recommend it i
assume if you're asking this you're
younger in your 20s and 30s what have
you
i would do nothing i would understand
that it's like a roller coaster and the
only time that you get hurt is when you
jump off the roller coaster stay on
there's going to be dips but then
eventually the roller coaster will be
riding on again 2008 happened people
freaked out sold by 2010 the market was
back
2019 2020 crash
by 2021 now we're at an all-time high
ride the roller coaster baby keep your
costs low and stay the course keep it
simple kiss methodology keep it simple
stupid talk is money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken